Ana's vase tusen is the Danish Peoples
party's new representative in the
European Parliament just 26 years old
he's already made the jump from the
folketing the Danish Parliament to
Brussels his platform is simple and
straightforward we don't think that
Europe should be a social Union we don't
think that they should interfere with
the numerous numerous issues in the
national States so we think that year
the EU should focus on what is good at
the free trade the cross-border problems
like climate and environments but they
should not interfere in the day-to-day
business of the national States more
Denmark and less Europe this was the
slogan that put the Danish People's
Party in first place in Denmark's
European parliamentary election and
doubled the number of MEP s the
right-wing populist Tsar sending to
Brussels it was an impressive showing
something for them to sing about
Anna's vase the son got his start in the
party's youth organization his colleague
mater Denker has been with the party
since it was founded in 1995 she lives
in the Copenhagen suburb of Villa where
the party nailed thirty five point nine
percent of the vote
her husband micah is also a DPP
representative the couple has three
children
they watch the images from election
night over and over still hardly able to
believe it's true both reject any form
of racism or xenophobia but they would
like to see passport checks at the
borders again even for EU citizens to
keep the influx of immigrants under
control your Danish if you feel Danish
in your heart and Danish is your native
language Denmark is the Danish people
that's how it is that's how it always
has been and how it always will be the
DPP holds up the specter of foreigners
even EU citizens coming to Denmark to
cash in on the generous state benefits
but Denmark urgently needs foreign
workers and so as Marlena vend of the
University of Copenhagen points out
there is no mention of the country
leaving the EU they want to stay in the
market but they hate everything else
about the EU and they aren't
particularly using a certain demography
that is about the elites are taking over
deciding everything from Brussels that
we as innocent people have no longer any
say in anything they very much use this
dichotomy between the elites sitting in
Brussels and and then the Danes as being
suppressed innocent you know people who
are without any power anymore all
sovereignty have been taken away from us
we are losing our identity our culture
the rise of the Danish People's Party is
a hot topic on Danish television
commentators say it profited from the
protest votes and as TV reporter on
aslong bela explains from having tossed
out it's more radical elements now
Denmark's third largest force in
parliament is consolidating its position
Thank You Raman deadfall Guruji there's
no doubt the Danish People's Party has
had an effect on the debate about
foreigners not only have the established
conservative and centrist parties become
more critical of foreigners but we've
seen even the social democrat go very
far in the same direction even the
socialist People's Party and left-wing
parties have let this party influence
their positions
floow2 sir now Anna's vase tusen is busy
with negotiations to form a coalition
for the European Parliament his party
has already sent the right-wing
populists from the Netherlands and
France packing racism is not acceptable
you of course you can critic criticize
religious fanaticism incite Christianity
and Islam or other religions but it's
not okay to to just people based on the
color of the skin so if they do latter
you've not accept that either so you can
say we have lots of red flags and that's
also why we have said no thank you to
join the group with the the pen and
buildest the members of the European
Parliament and the world are keeping a
close eye on how the right-wing parties
are shaping up